toutes les expéditions contre gênes ont
échoué les shadoks ont décidé de
l'amadouer en lui jouant de la musique
dans le cadre de la grande campagne
d'éducation des shadoks
nous assistons donc on vous dit à un
souvenir de musique shadow
la musique sadok colonnes le voyez
consiste est en grande partie à faire du
bruit avec n'importe quoi car c'était un
des principes de base de la musique
shadoks pour une oreille bien exercer il
n'y a pas de bruit qui ne puisse être
entendue comme une musique et
réciproquement
le tout est une question d'exercice
c'était assez pénible est assez lourd
mais il fallait persévérer car c'était
un autre principe de base la musique
shadoks
c'est en forgeant que l'on devient plus
ici